pour l'assaut final qui a quitté donc le
gmac le cnrs pour venir sur le plateau
du 7 8 pour nous parler d'un tout autre
sujet tout à fait mais on reste un petit
peu dans l'environnement mais dans
l'envié dans l'innovation dans l'option
donc ça paraissait impossible et
pourtant les premiers avions électriques
en taille réelle existe à vous avant de
vous en dire plus sur cette nouvelle
technologie moi j'ai pas la question
chaque jour je vous en prie
nous sommes allés demander l'avis aux
cinquante six mois sur cette nouvelle
technologie
et puis voir si ça leur semble
invraisemblable tout simplement
non je crois pas
je pense qu'avant tout est une preuve d
autonomie
que l'on serait que le kérosène c'est
pas terrible mais pour l'instant c'est
et utiliser quoi bien sûr chapelet décès
comme tous ici si on libère été utilisé
les sens ce serait mieux pour la
production et que cette erreur c'est
tout oui moi je suis collectrices it et
moi ce sera plus lent peut-être maison
blanche ne sera sécurisé ans peut-être
que les adultes n'y crois pas mais les
jeunes n'y croient j'aurais peur
j'aurais peur de prendre l'avion
électrique chez peu sécurisé avec nous
avions donc moi il y aura sûrement en
avenir plus écologique avec ça
avec les nouvelles énergies ça peut
avoir un avenir qu par un avion qui sont
qui peut qui utilisent du carburant et
du coup il peut lui ça peut-être un
avenir sûrement parce qu'il me semble
que j'ai vu à la télé mais c'est pas
pour maintenant
alors est ce que c'est pour maintenant
est-ce que ça a un avenir mais oui c'est
possible en apporter la preuve la preuve
j'ai lasours avant les méchants pato
17,8 suis allé voir lifan l'avion qui
est conçu en collaboration avec eads et
air & company une société basée à
toussus le noble l'engin a été explosé
la semaine dernière à l'aéroport des
images de patrick jacques de dixmude
je me trouve dans un hangar de
l'aéroport de toussus-le-noble derrière
moi lifan un avion tout électrique une
petite prouesse technologique qui va
permettre d'économiser les 30 à 40
litres de carburant qui sont nécessaires
pendant une heure de vol pour un biplace
comme celui ci par exemple alors les
fans ne peut pas encore volé vous allez
comprendre pourquoi et tout ça va nous
être expliquées par charles clerc
bonjour bonjour vous êtes le fondateur
et le président d'une compagnie qui
s'appelle air et compagnie tout à fait
qu est une école de pilotage donc basé à
toussus-le-noble
des entreprises majeures en fait du
secteur de la formation au pilotage à
quoi il sert cet avion c'est d'abord
pour la formation c'est ça alors tout
est fait c'est un avion biplace donc par
définition un avion école qui dans sa
version initiale serait initialement
vraiment consacré à la formation fait
des pilotes que ce soit des pilotes
privés mais aussi à terme des pilotes
professionnels mais il n'est encore
jamais volé alors est-ce que ça va
vraiment voulait alors oui oui oui oui
c'est vraiment volé je pense qu'on n'est
pas très loin en fait deux
que l'avion puisse voler
qu'est-ce qui manque la une et
certificats passer des tests oui oui
comme tout aéronef en fait que vous y
comme vous avez eu récemment la airbus
a350 en fait naturellement tous les
avions doivent être certifiés donc ça
des bureaux d'études qui passe par un
schéma de certification d'une autorité
qui est européenne qu'on appelle le a et
ça est en fait l'avion subit un certain
nombre de tests pour être officiellement
certifié et détenir ce qu'on appelle un
certificat de navigabilité alors vous
vous allez participer au cahier des
charges quelle particularité il a cet
avion il et j'imagine très léger pour
pouvoir être électrique c'est ça alors
oui et non puisque c'est un lion qui
fait en fait à peu près 500 kg donc on
n'est pas très très loin en fait d'un
avion ont dû de la masse classique d'un
avion-école simplement par le poids des
batteries
maintenant sa particularité en fait
c'est vraiment deux innovations majeures
ce type d'aéronef bon vous l'avez
largement évoqué un avion tout
électrique par définition ne consomme
plus de carburant donc c'est une
économie certaine pour notre
exploitation et vous avez naturellement
un deuxième fait qui est très sensible
en ce moment et bien sûr l'environnement
avec les nuisances sonores puisque en
fait un moteur électrique ne
fait plus de bruit en fait le dernier
bruit qu'on peut avoir en fait sur un
avion c'est uniquement liée à la
rotation en fait des pales qui se situe
là mais qui ont été carré n'est en fait
dans une conception absolument nouvelles
qui permettent de limiter encore le web
et le prix parce que certes on fait des
économies à l'usagé mais à l'acquisition
j'imagine que c'est très cher alors
c'est là on est intervenu c'est là
qu'ils étaient surtout notre hall par
rapport à des ce2 à réussir à rester les
pieds sur terre sur ce type de prix on
n'a pas de prix officiel à vous donner
aujourd'hui sur ce type de machine en
tout cas je ne vois pas de c'est disons
que l'objectif est de s'approcher en
tout cas du coût d'un avion école
classique qui on pourrait trouver en
fait avec une motorisation classique à
essence avec un coût qui sera forcément
important mais vous savez quand vous
économiser 40 litres à l'heure de vol
alors qu'il vous faut juste une heure
pour recharger des batteries obtenir
presque une heure d'autonomie et alors
il s'est terré consulter une amp ont
énormément comment ça se passe alors
on se branche comme il nous inquiète
tout à fait c'est à peu près le même
principe vous avez 60 kilowatts en fait
à recharger on a priori à peu près une
heure de recharge et qui vous permet de
voler en condition entre 45 minutes et
une heure pouvoir sachant que l'objectif
est de certifier à l'aéronef en fait
avec des batteries qui puisse voler
pendant 1h30 c'est balla c'est un des
inconvénients aussi peut-être c'est
qu'on peut voler moins longtemps c'est
une innovation c'est le début
comme toute innovation elle débute c'est
un projet bêta
une heure trente de vol c'est vrai que
c'est peu un avion à motorisation apic
un moteur à pistons qui va consommer de
l'essence enfin vous nous avez toujours
son autonomie de 4 à 5 heures de vol là
on est clairement dans une innovation
mais il faut savoir que c'est le début
et je pense qu'en tout cas c'est déjà un
beau projet qui peut nous permettre
d'économiser du carburant est d'avoir un
véritable avion temps vous vous êtes
pilote également qu'est ce que ça change
concrètement quand on est dans le
cockpit pour
pilotage est ce qu'il ya une différence
alors non non non pas du tout pas du
tout je n'ai pas ces expériences là pour
moi jouer plutôt sur des gros de gros
avions
maintenant clairement d'un point de vue
aérodynamique il ya aucune raison en
fait que l'avion se comporte
différemment c'est un avion qui va être
aussi bien utilisée pour faire de
l'école que pour faut refaire en fait de
la voltige ou tout autre type de vol
les fondamentaux sont autant là alors la
vitesse on est sur un avion qui va
évoluent au fort de ma part aux environs
de 150 km heure en vitesse de croisière
naturellement les moteurs sont toujours
plus réactifs en fait vous avez moins
d'inertie en fait sur des moteurs avec
un fonctionnement électrique parce que
la puissance est tout de suite
disponible mais savent on a le même
problème aujourd'hui refaire les mêmes
avantages sur des voitures électriques
etc non il ya beaucoup de beaucoup
d'avantagés finalement assez peu de
d'inconvénients ya quelques années vous
croyez pas que c'était possible de le
faire un avion vraiment qu'ils volent
électrique est ce que on se dirige vers
les gros porteurs électrique aussi en
tout cas c'est pareil que veut faire aux
ads ce projet est né en 2011 en fait
pendant le salon du bourget donc pas
socialiste au salon du bourget qui vient
de se terminer là mais il ya deux ans
avec eads et un certain nombre de
partenaires et eads s'était dit voilà
est-ce qu'on est capable de faire
aujourd'hui un avion électrique en tout
cas d'être les premiers à mettre le pied
dans quelque chose de peut-être beaucoup
plus gros enfin une véritable innovation
technologique lifan est le première la
première pierre à cet édifice derrière
bien sûr que une compagnie comme eads je
pense investit pas dans ce genre de
travaux pour s'arrêter sur ce type
d'avion est en tout cas souhaite
peut-être à terme peut-être que dans
cinquante ans nos avions gros porteurs
et en tout cas des avions qui font des
mini régulière long courrier pour
peut-être volé grâce en fait à une
énergie 100 % électrique pour finir
l'agenda de cet avion il n'est pas
encore industrialisés par exemple à caen
on espère enfin eads espère en tout cas
pouvoir
faire une certification d'ici deux ans
et l'horizon 2015 pouvoir commencer à
commercialiser en fait ce type de
produit qui serait vraiment le premier
avion certifié pour l'usa général et
pour la licence générale en électrique
et ça ouvre des portes absolument
extraordinaire pour diminuer le coût de
l'aviation générale et pour de nouveaux
l'aviation accessible au grand public
parce qu'aujourd'hui une heure de vol à
saku de 850 200 250 euros en coûts de
base et ça permettrait vraiment de
réduire les coûts de d'intéresser
l'aviation au plus grand nombre et de
développer cet outil magnifique merci
beaucoup ils ont pris
voilà un outil magnifique ses chars
leclerc kg dit sophie moi en tout cas ce
que j'ai noté et ça revient sur les
micro trottoirs qu'on a entendu il ya
une heure de recherches pour 45 minutes
à une heure de vol on est dans son petit
avion électrique
il tombe en panne qu'est ce qui se passe
c'est la panique non
alors comme sur un avion classique il ya
une réserve donc des batteries de
secours parce que c'est avec tree qu'un
appât du sceau de motor a aucun mode des
remparts vraiment d'un tout électrique
sinon on peut également en faire un
atterrissage d'urgence en planant et
puis en dernier recours il reste le bon
vieux parachute pour sauter
mais ça pose est rassurant effectivement
des problèmes de sécurité à régler
puisque ses batteries au lithium elles
ont posé des problèmes
janvier dernier avec le boeing 787 qui
utilise en partie oui en partie je porte
à ce modèle 787 il vole littéralement
les tricks accord pas du tout alors sauf
que voilà en utilisant ses batteries les
avions étaient cloués au sol pendant
trois mois de janvier à mars en raison
d'importants problèmes de surchauffe des
batteries est donc là ce qui était en
jeu bah c'était des éventuels court
circuit la surchauffe de tout l'avion
carrément donc c'est donc un principe
qui a des risques bien réels qu'il faut
maîtriser avant de passer à des avions
plus gros je vais pas vous parler de
maîtrise de ce n'est pour l'instant avec
l'avion ne vole pas il a passé deux pour
voler mais exprime mon petit peu comment
est née l'aviation électrique alors
l'aviation électrique bon je vais je
vais poser la question à savoir c'est
pas moi qui vous avez vous noté que le
premier vol d'avion électrique a été
fait en france en 1900 en 2007 pardon en
2007 donc cesser les français se sont
encore qui courait premiers veulent
électrique c'est pas
50 1 livid c'était dans les hautes-alpes
mais pour répondre à votre question je
vous propose d'écouter un chargé
d'innovation de eads qui nous explique
plus précisément d'où vient cette idée
de mettre de l'électrique dans les
avions
l'aviation électrique à l'aîné en fait
grâce au modélisme grâce à l'apparition
des batteries au lithium qui apportent
des rendements
vraiment supérieurs et des performances
vraiment supérieur et grâce à ses
batteries et bien le modélisme donc les
petits avions électriques des petits
hélicoptères électriques ont pu naître
et grâce à cela les petits avions comme
celui ci comme le co écrit on peut
apparaître donc c'est très récent c'est
vraiment grâce aux batteries donc c'est
les batteries qui comme il le dit qui
est un des enjeux vraiment fort de cette
poursuite de l'innovation de l'avion et
c'est ça qui a permis de vraiment
réussir à créer un avion entièrement
électrique c'est ça qui va falloir
continuer à développer continuer à
pouvoir réduire le poids des batteries
pour être toujours de plus en plus
puissant puisque les batteries c'est
bien simple plus elles sont légères plus
elles vont pouvoir porter l'avion plus
facilement et pas rentrer dans le cercle
vicieux de jeu mais plus de batterie
donc c'est plus long mais moi j'avais
comme une question sur les batteries
parce que moi je suis resté sur des
idées de batteries qui roule dans
certaines voitures électriques de marque
japonaise un bon terrain le nom malgré
tout elles sont quand même assez
imposant dans le coffre d'une voiture
alors on se dit un avion qui pèse 500 kg
les batteries elles sont énormes alors
c'est ce fameux rapport pauvre essence
est bien là nous il s'agit en fait
visiblement de batteries qui ont le
format d'une page a4 on les empile en
série
pour obtenir l'attention dont on a
besoin et et voilà ça fait beaucoup de
progrès
lorsqu'on croyait que tout ça un avenir
alors s'offrir le spécialiste du cnous
il ya deux écoles ya deux écoles donc
comme on a vu monsieur claire de r &
company lui est persuadé que mabri
effectivement c'est l'avenir il nous
dirait pas le contraire
notamment parce que parce que elle et
les énergies fossiles se termine bientôt
il va falloir trouver une autre solution
qu'on a envie de dire c'est évidemment
l'avenir mais je vous dis il y a deux
écoles quand on interroge par contre les
membres de la déesse eux parlent
peut-être plutôt d'une alternative
possible dans l'avenir de l'aviation
parce qu'il va falloir encore de très
grandes innovations pour avoir un avion
gros porteur qui arrive au tout
électrique et ça c'est pas envisagée
avant 2050 accord donc ces maternités un
peu comme les voitures il ya une offre
de voitures électriques mais le marché
reste quand même au thermique en tout
cas je pense que ça serait un avion qui
ne pourrait ravir les habitants de
toussus-le-noble saint cyr l'école qui
se plaignent du bruit puisque là pour le
coup il y aurait vraiment plus de bruit
d'un merci pour cet éclairage on va
maintenant passer l'info en + absolument
l'info on part bientôt en vacances faut
bientôt les vacances alors en ce début
de saison estivale une étude easy panel
nous apprend que nous serrions 47% à
voyager avec notre ordinateur dans nos
bagages un chiffre qui atteint même 60
pour cent pour cent chez les 18 24 ans
et chez les catégories
socioprofessionnelles supérieures est
donc globalement une majorité de
français prévoit d'utiliser leur
ordinateur en moyenne plus de 30 minutes
par jour un usage relativement raisonnée
donc et à la majorité pour des activités
de loisirs